cardi b is officially a mom of two
the rapper and her husband offset
welcomed their baby boy together on
saturday cardi shared the exciting news
alongside a photo of her cradling her
son while sitting next to offset in the
hospital cardi captioned the sweet
family photo
9-4-21 i just get too emotional when
come to my kid in a statement to e-t
cardian offset said quote we are so
overjoyed to finally meet our son he is
already loved so much by family and
friends and we can't wait to introduce
him to his other siblings
offset later shared another picture from
the hospital writing chapter five it's
gonna mean everything chapter five would
be a reference to all of the migos
rapper's kids
aside from culture offset's daughter
with cardi he is also a father to
another daughter and two sons from
previous relationships
there's some big big things on the way
big bangs in june the 28 year old wap
rapper surprised fans with her pregnancy
reveal at the 2021 bt awards and cardi
has been sharing her pregnancy journey
on social media ever since
oh my gosh
the now mom of two also posted these
beautiful maternity photos of her
growing family
and let's take a moment to gush over how
cute culture will be as a big sister
she's so cute i love her in this photo
the proud mom predicted how her
two-year-old will handle being the big
sis
pointing out that they will have the
same age difference as cardi and her
younger sister hennessy
she wrote i just know these two will
love each other so much and argue so
much since they're three years apart
just like me and henny but one thing for
sure is they'll have each other's back
like no one else ever will
oh guys this is me and my best friend
your mommy's best friend yeah yay you
love me
yeah forever
and next to this pic of hubby offset
cradling her baby bump cardi wrote we
listened to each other communicated
prayed and then god blessed us and our
family with another little blessing
our home feels so blissful and very busy
but we are ready and so happy
thank you so much everyone for the
congrats and well wishes
in 2019 when culture was less than a
year old cardi told dt she was already
looking to give her baby girl some
siblings
what does it mean to be a mother
it means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's indescribable
it's like
like
love joy it's a
switch
you know what i'm saying there's like a
automatic smile
so it's everything
[Music]